now each day about 100 pounds of food
are going out of a box to people in need
in southern nevada it's just one of many
services offered at catholic charities
no questions asked christian casares
shows us how everyone can benefit from
this even those without legal status
it's very important to us because we
know when we come we're gonna get our
breakfast we're gonna get our lunch
we're gonna get our dinner here
i met yasmin lopez and her family at
catholic charities
as they picked up their monthly food box
a free service they have been receiving
for over a decade the mother of six
telling me that it's a constant struggle
to have food on their table according to
catholic charities latinos make up to 30
percent of their clients but only
consume 22 percent of their food all are
welcome and all you got to do is reach
out leslie carman with the organization
says one of their many food programs
offered is the hands of hope food pantry
it's kind of designed that way to be
like a grocery store so it offers
dignity to people who may be ashamed to
ask you when they get here they're like
oh there's usually music playing it's
joyful colorful you know it kind of
lifts their spirits a little bit and if
they have young children that come with
them you know they don't really know the
difference so they don't know that
they're asking for help
carmen says their main mission is to
feed the community and offer a helping
hand
regardless of the person's legal status
we do see people who are maybe are a
little unsure and they may be scared to
come out but please don't be
you know they're more than welcome to
come in we offer services to anyone
a promise this family hopes others in
their same situation can take advantage
of we have food on the table we got
stuff to go to school and
happiness you know it just we got food
and that's the main point nice to meet
you guys nice to meet you guys thank you
christian casadas 8 news now